mistletoe it's not the harmless plant of
Christmas cheer that you think mistletoe
or viscum album is actually a parasitic
plant its seed lodges itself into tree
branches and mercilessly sucks the life
out of the host branch which withers and
dies a metaphor for love
ancient Europeans were so impressed by
these vampiric plants they began to see
them as mystical and strangely enough
all healing one Celtic ritual used
mistletoe in an elixir to cure
infertility the viagra of the Iron Age
if you will medieval folk hung mistletoe
in front of their homes to scare away
passing demons and stuck it under their
pillows to induce prophetic dreams and
the whole kissing under the mistletoe
thing this tradition first appeared in
16th century England when a lady was
told it was bad luck if she refused
clever but the origin of the name is
less romantic it comes from two
anglo-saxon words mystile which means
dung and 10 which means twig so you
could translate mistletoe as poop on a
stick so how does a turkey make it to
your plate it all starts with an act of
love usually artificial insemination